hallo leute diese woche geht es bei
super easy german um das werk finden
wir zeigen euch wie es konjugieren könnt
und in verschiedenen zeitformen
verwenden könnt los geht's präsenz ich
finde du findest er sie es findet wir
finden
ihr findet sie finden alina findet eine
brieftasche sophie findet einen rucksack
schließlich findet sie ein portemonnaie
und cloud ist janosch findet ein
smartphone
er macht 111 ii wie findet ihr das war
so viel ich finde deine haare schön ich
bin seine augen schön ich finde dein
mund schön ich finde dein charakter
schön danke ich finde deinen pulli schön
oh danke präteritum ich fand du fandest
er sie es fand wir fanden ihr fandet sie
fanden
janosch wie fandest du den film ich fand
den ich fand den ok aber was weiß ich
bisschen langweilig oder
was machst du denn da sorry ich fand
kein mülleimer
ich fand das respektlos ich fand das
cool perfekt ich habe gefunden
du hast gefunden er sie es hat gefunden
wir haben gefunden ihr habt gefunden
sie haben gefunden habt ihr schon
freunde in deutschland gefunden
wir haben eine lösung gefunden sophie
was hast du heute gefunden
ich habe heute eine tasche gefunden
alina und was hast du heute gefunden
ich habe heute eine brieftasche gefunden
und janosch was hast du heute gefunden
ich habe ein iphone gefunden wir haben
einen schönen neuen ort gefunden als ich
in japan war habe ich ganz viele neue
freunde gefunden futur ich werde finden
du wirst finden er sie es wird finden
wir werden finden
ihr werdet finden sie werden finden so
viel ich werde meine große liebe finden
glaube ich auch
ich habe meinen ohrring verloren
ich werde ihn wahrscheinlich nie wieder
finden ihr werdet den perfekten job
finden
eines tages werden wir eine richtig
schöne wohnung finden
alle deutschen werben besitzen zwei
formen des konjunktiv 2 wir bringen euch
heute beide bei weil wir abhängig vom
kontext mal die eine mal die andere form
verwenden
manchmal klingt die reine form
natürlicher und manchmal die andere
deshalb solltet ihr beide lernen
konjunktiv 2 ich finde du fändest er sie
es ende
wir finden ihr findet sie finden
wie findest du es wenn du größer werden
das finde ich praktisch
ich würde finden du würdest finden sie
es würde finden wir würden finden
ihr würdet finden sie würden finden ohne
geld würde man keine wohnung in berlin
finden
ich liebe herbstwetter ich würde es
schön finden wenn der herbst länger wäre
das war unsere super easy german episode
zu dem werk finden wenn jetzt euer
deutsch noch weiter verbessern möchtet
dann probiert doch mal unsere app sieht
lang aus dort haben wir unter anderem
ein vokabeltrainer mit dem ihr die
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln
trainieren könnte bis bald
[Musik]